Not for the faint-hearted.
A glass bridge has been erected in China...
...and people are already taking a crack at it.
Brave volunteers and staff thrashed sledgehammers down...
...onto the glass-bottom bridge beneath them...
...to test the strength and sturdiness of the structure.
And with the bridge being suspended a whopping 300 meters above ground,...
...that definitely took some guts.
Israeli Haim Dotan is the chief architect behind the project,...
...which its creators claim is the largest glass bridge of its kind in the world.
The courageous volunteers were harnessed...
...to the side of the bridge as a precaution.
But reassuringly, none of them managed to break through the glass.
And just to drive the point home, a 15-ton SUV...
...was then driven over the glass just to hammer in its strength.